[Musique]
j'ai appris de source sûre que vous
allez vous rendre concert de kenji rien
contre garçons c'est pas le problème
mais avec une personne autour de la
table
de surcroît de sexe féminin tonya tonya
tonya et ça monte là je ne vois pas je
ne vois pas l'info média
je me tape des médias le moment où je
vous parle mais là c'est un truc là je
parle de vous et d'hommes mais oui c'est
ça me rend mes côtés sans toi tu
m'emmerdes avec les français comme vous
respectez belaiba la divine kényan mais
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle elle est
dense où j'ai appris alors je vous
deviez vous rendre au concert de kenji
avec agathe outre bon avec agathe deux
ans quand vous avez appris ça il n'y a
pas très longtemps
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure pour nous
si j'avais appris hier soir serait pas
là ce soir jour une pause pub
manque de bol pour voir les soit
maintenant vos questions donc j'ai fait
deux ans que nous deux on est proches
deux ans qu'on se tourne un peu autour
qu'on fait monter le désir
je ne veux pas de couple à trois je ne
supporterais pas ça donc à un moment
donné choisissez voilà donc est ce que
c'est vrai déjà vous devez aller au
concert de kenji avec agathe taux
d'intérêt tout vous avez l'impôt un côté
moi toute l'histoire je sais que tu as
besson s'en fout là sont jamais dit moi
de le médecin pas tourner de problème on
s'en fout de la somme toute l'histoire
allez-y à côté ce que je veux dire c'est
vrai aussi c'est faux j'ai appris ça de
la part d'un de mes amis qui est un
producteur je vais pas vous dire qui
c'est peu importe mais qu'est ce qu'on
s'en foutent dehors qui s'est fait par
eux mêmes ce sont vous êtes doué vous
quand même c'est comme si vous allez
voir votre femme en disant je sais que
t'es trompé et quelques et vous y tenir
mais quitte la dynamique heatley 10
importants qui te l'a dit on s'en fout
tu l'a trompée
sur contre attaque est ce que c'est vrai
et puis je te sens mal ça le rsa les
vrais questionne quoi la vraie question
c'est est-ce que agathe va au concert
pour vous faire plaisir
ou est ce que vraiment ils aiment kenji
est ce que ça vous gêne pas les révéler
qu'un gamin tu absolument pas cyril vous
faites ce que vous voulez de votre vie
jean-michel bon pas du tout qu'ils se
mêlent de ses coûts
[Rires]
jean-michel je suis pas sûr a avoué dit
la vérité la vérité il semble un peu con
mais je vais proposer qu'un jeu l'aiment
beaucoup mathieu je vais proposer de
venir chez moi demain voilà échanger et
de regarder un concert des village
people en streaming
il veut pas évidemment ça me gêne pas de
façon j'ai changé ma place pour rien au
monde pour aller voir que les gee-gees
réservé aux soirées sont précieuses vous
n'allez pas les gaspiller avec ce conte
quand même d'un million pardon peut-il
auparavant que tu répondes juste un mot
franchement mon mec se barricadent
exclusion c'est pas la première meuf qui
passe elle est tout à fait respectable
depuis cette émission ces matériaux
c'est plutôt 5 émissions que target
oui c'est surtout ça le fond m alors oui
bout alors savoir pourquoi gathimba
parce qu'a priori je pensais pas qu'elle
était fan inscrit le sens au théâtre
michel sardou serait même problème
oui même violence oui moi ça me choque
parce que plus le temps qui vous propose
aller à des concerts et vous dis
maintenant c'est beaucoup mieux mais pas
pour musique angie non non non c'est moi
a proposé 4
est ce que ça vous aide
non moi ça me choque pas et puis c'est
pas un scoop un vous aimez les belles
femmes et puis vous aimez la mauvaise
mais non mais les mecs nommé racontez là
alors c'est en tout bien tout honneur
vous êtes pourquoi les femmes la
compagnie de belles femmes je veux dire
non mais oh mais sa tournée sur un
groupe de l'année mathieu alors la
grande vallée on écoute tous les deux
d'accord car j'essaie de vous sauver
j'ai toujours la vérité
la mairie lui tellement crevard commis
les heat aura invite au concert mais
c'est toi qui paye les chéris alors vous
dire toute la vérité sur cette histoire
juste une question cyril on est que la
menace de mathieu de quitter tpm tête
ont pesé dans la balance le fraja
padilha lors la face à ça les chéris
vous dire et je vous donnerai toute la
lumière sur cette histoire dans un
instant à ce que vous avez entendu une
rumeur comme que jl au concert de kenji
demain avec agathe à ses deux mains
alors c'est demain elle débarque agathe
du coup toute la vérité donc là on met
cartes sur table oui ah bah oui à mon
prince vous pouvez pas y aller
enfin cyril merci voilà votre mail
donc j'ai c'est moi qui ai eu deux
places pour le concert de kenji on m'a
gentiment offert ses places et je sais
que cyril est fan inconditionnel de
kenji que j'aime beaucoup moins aussi
prochain les pommes et jean-michel
n'était pas disponible
donc j'ai gentiment proposé ses places à
ses rivales chantier en
tout bien tout honneur je sais que le
coeur de cyril est pris non pas par
matthieu delormeau même s'ils veulent
eux il veut le fantasme et jusqu'au bout
donc nous allons nous rendre au concert
de kenji en ami et mathieu tu pourras
faire ce que tu veux mais tu ne réussira
pas à briser cette amitié ça lui sinon
elle vous invite
et bim réel et mal à l'autre traînait
elle accepte
[Applaudissements]
oui bah oui mais c'est comme ça oui oui
mais vous êtes vraiment c'est de
l'amitié si vous n'aimez pas l'amitié
dont d'écouté pas les oreilles je savais
plus ce que c'est l'amitié je peux venir
aussi les médias trois et un lob on
active
rassurez vous je trouverais mois ces
deux coups de téléphone j'ai des amis
partout
angie je l'appelle maintenant à los
montes ken green lama une place de choix
dans la fosse aux récits réfléchir ont
mené jusqu'à demain soir pour annuler si
je prends la décision d'y aller
ouais ce que vous faites honnêtement
lundi qu'est ce qu'on fait pour de vrai
de vrai bien plus viril avis qu'est ce
que vous faites
je ne serais pas là lundi omar ait plus
jamais tu en fais trop là mathieu nomme
mathieu d'accord laissez moi un jour
pour prendre la ville je ne serais pas
là laissez-moi 24 heures mais vous le
laissez faire du chantage chantage
affectif
oui mais gênant ça me touche non mais
c'est vrai moi aussi ce parent d'élève
où j'ai déjà réfléchi
[Rires]
m
mais laissez-moi 24 heures il vous
rendez compte que si jamais j'avais pas
eu l'info mais tout ça ce serait fait
dans mon dos ouais bah c'est souvent ce
qui se passe à l'école